this talk is going to be an unscientific
survey of Python interpreters and I know
in the room of these some actual
scientists so I really do mean it it's
unscientific if you want to follow along
that bitly link will get you to a gist
on github of the jupiter notebook that
this is all written in I'm actually
using rise to do this so this is all
live off of the notebook you can use the
azure ml studio if you want to actually
download the ipython notebook and load
it up and directly play with something I
was using MB Viewer tutor doc org when I
gave this talk Saturday in Toronto at
PyCon Canada but I was getting a 502 or
there today so you just got the gist
manually and do whatever you want to
view the notebook as I said though free
hosting view and if you want on others
to do with that out of the way if my
keyboard wants to suddenly not work
that's not good
area okay so just a quick thing about me
my name is Brett cannon I've been a core
developer since 2003 so about 12 years
now blog Google+ Twitter github blah
blah blah
basically just google my name you'll
find me quick thanks to Microsoft who I
work for
specifically the Python team and yes
there is a Python team at Microsoft in
the data analytics group in Azure sent
me out here we're hiring our team at
Python jobs at Microsoft comm general
you can just go to cruised up Microsoft
comm I've now done what I might control
duty so we will actually start talking
so what is this about so this is about
interpreters that actually implement
Python I have a certain requirement to
have a interpreter considered to be
implementing Python to be discussed here
so first thing it has to implement a
version of Python that I consider modern
that's 2.7 obviously or 3.3 at a minimum
which unfortunately cuts out pi PI 3 but
based on an informal survey on Twitter
people said they wanted at least three
three so and pi PI 3 is only at 3.2 at
the moment I said I had to run most of
the grand unified benchmark suite which
you can find at
HG python.org / benchmarks it's actually
the unladen swallow benchmarks basically
cleaned up for work on Python 3 and to
work across all these interpreters I
also said I had to work on at least OS
10 or Linux or Windows basically a
chance everyone in this room had one of
these os's so I don't know of any
interpreters that run on some
marginalized OS but I'd say that had at
least be some form of a requirement so
I'm gonna go through a quick history of
the interpreters of Python because it's
surprisingly rich and I think it's
something people kind of overlook that
there's actually a good tradition in
this community to actually love this
language enough that they want to
actually re-implement the bloody thing
because it's not easy but people want to
do it and they do it a lot and I think
it should be recognized so if you don't
know Guido actually started creating
Python in December of 1989 while working
in CWI in the Netherlands to develop a
scripting language for the amoeba
distributed operating system and it was
basically an internal thing at CWI until
1991 when he released version 0.9.0 on
all those sources back when use net was
a thing and then three years later we
got cpython 1.0 obviously not the
18-month release cycle we have now but
hey at least you got there but one thing
one thing to notice though is I mean
five years ago from nothing to one back
then and open source was a little cut
not a huge thing and not too bad
and then in 1997 Jim hugenon released J
Python the first alternative
implementation of Python so if you
notice we went from December of 89 so
basically 1990 this is 97 to having an
alternative implementation of the
language which i think is honestly
really fast if you really think about it
I mean it's seven years to for someone
for the popularity of Python to get to
enough of a point for someone to be
crazy enough to go I like this enough
I'm just gonna reopen it just because I
want to and Jim's new
we'll be seen again in this another
sliding you'll really true they have
nuts Jim is but any 1987 at seven years
I think that's actually surprisingly
fast in a real testament to how much we
all love language subsequently one year
later in ninety eight Christian schism
Erdal developed stackless version 1.0 in
case you don't know about stackless it
does what it sounds like it takes the
stack out of C Python which you really
care about when you need to do some
large scaling in terms of lots of
simultaneously burning calculations such
G event kind of builds off this kind of
idea it's that kind of parallelization
if you know of the game EVE Online from
cpp games in Iceland they actually run
their entire server for that game in
stackless one year after that
barry warsaw renamed jeep right j python
to dry thumb as we now know a pike and
had the 2.0 release they actually
released new versions faster than we did
back since i was only two years instead
of this for to go to version one for
them but good for them
hey we've all we all really faster now
to either two years later in 2001 the
parrot April Fool's joke occurred for
those you don't know that April Fool's
Guido and Larry wall of Python of Perl
released a April Fool's joke creating a
new language called parrot that was
going to be the marriage of Perl and
Python and it was actually fairly
elaborate to the point that O'Reilly
actually did an interview with them and
published it on already calm so this is
well not one this was not a small little
April Fool's joke it was also kind of
the start of a tradition of doing
occasional April Fool's jokes in Python
the ever from future import fluffle or
some other things you'll know some of
the previous April Fool's jokes that
we've done look in the peps you'll find
a couple 401 for instance for April
first anyway just google around you'll
get a couple chuckles
so that was 2001 2003 Armen rego really
psycho 1.0 which is probably the first
JIT ever done for Python it was a real
deep hack into C Python and very
specific to numerix but at least proved
that there was a reasonable chance that
this would make sense they added yet one
year later after that though our min and
people on the Python Germany Python HD
emailing list started a chat and go hey
you know what we should implement Python
in Python and then what sure why not and
that's that we ended up with Phi Phi
seriously it was literally just people
talking on a mailing list and just going
why don't we just do this why not
obviously a tentative subsuming parts of
checklist and all psycho and as we all
know it it's actually one of the fastest
implementations of Python at this point
which no one thought of at all way back
then because that was back when they
were like 30 times slower because it was
literally Python in Python that was
before it was also the year Dan Segal
ski got a part of the face dan was the
creator of the parrot VM which was
actually named after the 2001 April
Fool's joke and was going to be the
official VM for Perl 6 whenever Perl 6
Evans and basically he made a bet with
Guido that parrot could run Python
faster than C Python dan actually never
finished because dan didn't realize how
dynamic Python is and thus how crazy
everyone else is for implementing Python
other than C Python could actually do
want to do it but there was a donation
to charity if he did it so we did stick
a pie and dance face there are photos
online if you want to find out 2006 Jim
Q cannon who created try thon created
ironpython and reset app icon this was
Jim trying to prove a point basically
people have said 'don't net was not
going to be good for dynamic dynamic
programming languages so jim decided all
right I'll prove that I'll try to
implement Python and show them where
they're really screwing up it turned out
they weren't and Jim actually did it and
actually worked out reasonably well this
is actually what led to the dynamic
language runtime
Annette and Jim actually going to work
for Microsoft for a few years 2008 was
unlined swallow that was Google's
projects by a couple core devs there
they tried to basically use the LLVM
jets to speed up Python
unfortunately the LLVM jet was very
buggy back then and they spent most of
their time fixing bugs in LVM then
actually trying to speed up python but
we did get our benchmark suite from them
and so it wasn't a complete waste of
time
2013 the micro Python Kickstarter
campaign launched which is probably the
first alternative partial Python 3
implementation of Python 3 it's not a
full implementation because it is
designed run on little micro boards but
it is the first alternative to at least
to some extent of Python 3 excuse me
2014 things heated up yet again in the
interpreter space piston from Dropbox
was announced at PyCon I'll talk I have
a slide about that later
pi PI 3 had its first stable release and
that was the first alternative
implementation of Python 3 and then just
this year pigeon which I have a slide on
later I was announced up idea to Seattle
Russell Keith Magee just this past
September at Vancouver Python day and
that's VLC and I will discuss that and
then the last big announcement was that
the BBC micro bits if ever you have seen
is this little controller board that's
going to be given to every 7th grader in
the UK is going to be running Python
things to micro Python so pretty soon
they're going to be more Python 3
programmers thanks to the UK then they
probably are anywhere else and will
outnumber Python 2 programmers so if you
don't switch to Python 3 your jobs will
week in trouble once those kids graduate
got a pitch Python 3 somehow right okay
so the interpreters there's about four
of them that meet my criteria that it
laid out at the beginning which I have a
CC Python it's implemented see shock we
all know that it does obviously work
with C extensions it is available on all
the major operating systems and it's
obviously the most compatible because
people basically implicitly decide that
if it works on C Python it's got to be
right
much the dismay of pie-pie people we are
willing to fix things that are badly
defined so not totally true anyway
there's also dry thong which is
implemented Java and will run anywhere
JDK 7 well so that's pretty much all the
major operating systems there's partial
secant extensible extension
compatibility thanks to a project called
J called giant and I it's still being
actively developed so I don't know how
far they are in terms of compatibility
but it is being worked on it is the
second oldest as you saw since 97 and it
currently supports Python 2.7
there's obviously pi pi which is written
what's called our python a subset of
python itself which basically can be
have type reference run on it
it supports C extensions through
actually three possible ways CFO Phi is
the newest one C types if you want to go
that route I advise you don't and CP pyy
which comes out of CERN although the web
page actually basically is a 404 so I
don't know how active it's being
developed but pipe I listed it is
historically the fastest Python
interpreter and I'll have numbers to
show later where you can make that
decision of whether that's still true or
not mystery how does any word that it
does work on Linux OS ten in Windows and
obviously convert because currently
supports 2.7 and 3.2 and I should
mention if you didn't hear pipe I did
release person for just last week or the
week before so they did have a very big
new release recently and then lastly is
ironpython implemented c-sharp they use
a project called ironclad that came out
of revolver systems they were doing
their custom spreadsheet and that will
work on any platform with net 3.5 or
higher which is pretty much everyone
thanks to mono and also done that being
open sourced and it supports the Python
2.7 so what's coming down the pipeline
if people continue to get money and have
the time and inclination to continue to
work those projects that have been
announced one project is pidgin I should
just give a disclaimer I work on this
part-time myself at Microsoft
it's basically a perfect concept to add
a JIT to C Python so the idea is papaya
has shown that jits are great for Python
but obviously they have a slight
compatibility problem with C extension
modules if you don't use CF Fi
so Dino veal and who used to work on the
ironpython project basically after this
passed PyCon in April decided oh why not
let's just see if we can add the dotnet
JIT to C Python and get python 300
faster with its own jet so this is a
proof of concept that he started where
we're going to hopefully show that we
can actually speed things up with the
jet and then push patches up into C
Python so that you can basically with
either a flag on the command line or
literally just an import get a JIT
activated for your Python code and have
it just work and I'll have numbers on
this on whether where we are with this
so far piston which I mentioned earlier
was announced in 2014 at the language
summit at PyCon this is being sponsored
by Dropbox and being actively developed
they're using LOV M for the JIT Maps
like a million swallow but the
difference is about seven years of bug
fixes so they're actually showing for
their own benchmarks at twenty five
percent speed up already for C Python
although they are not fully compliant
yet in terms of compatibility but they
are getting there it seems like and they
there's definite promise it is only
targeted towards Ben tude and two point
seven though because it is specific for
drop boxes servers I think they're open
though to open it to other platforms and
then last there's also vo C which I
mentioned was announced in Vancouver
just this past September basically
Russell Keith McGee of Jango wants
Python on mobile you on iOS you have
Objective C which is compatible with C
so that's taking hurt taken care of by C
Python but that does not deal with the
Java of Android so the way I've said in
people seem to like it it being said is
and he's trying to take it from Java
Java Java on Android to Python Python
Android Python Python Java but basically
transparently Python into Java so this
is not like joy on work it's a
interpreter implemented in Java and so
there's actually in the Neve aloof he's
actually literally trying to translate
Python code
to Java code so you can compile straight
to class files to then put on to an
Android device it's obviously really new
cuz saying he'd just announced in
September but he's hoping to basically
get Python 3 under Android and lastly a
quick mention of sky Thawne which was
announced at this past language summit
it's apparently a from scratch the
implementation of Python with no Gil in
for Python 3 unfortunately it was
announced then and we were told it was
gonna be open sourced in about a week or
so and we've not heard anything since so
I have no clue where it's at but it was
we at least know somewhere in someone's
code repo there exists a non Gil version
of C Python written from scratch for
Python 3 that we think works
valley's we've been told ok now there
might be various reasons why you can't
change your interpreter so there are
other ways to speed up but not really
new to this crowd there's always scythe
on because that'll compile straight to C
and in certain is that could be faster
when you had type annotations that they
use it's also another way to get
compatibility or knock better they build
to access c code when you have to write
the the hot part of your inner loops or
actually access a c library there's
always number from continuum the great
thing about number is it slowly just
decorators so just hack it on to
something that's running a little slow
and if it's numeric code it should just
run faster so it's dirt cheap to try so
i definitely recommend if you're doing
numerix to profile your code figure out
who's running slow tech on the decorator
and just see what happens and then
obviously lastly there's CF of 5 from
the PI pi team it's a quick way to wrap
C code that will work with both C Python
and pi PI and honestly it's easier than
hand wrapping C code that you might need
a wrap whether you're doing once again
for speed or you're coming to interface
with some other chukka C code
now this look at some pretty plots so as
I said this is unscientific everything
you're about to look at was using using
benchmarked on this little machine right
here using the granion friend benchmarks
suite from Python I tried to use a 64
bit every interpreter when I could which
basically means I've 32-bit one on for
pi PI because they don't have the 64-bit
windows and everyone else's 64 a bit now
the key thing to read on these graphs on
these charts is everything is relative
to see Python 2.7 point 10 and it's a
measurement of how long the benchmark
took compared to how long it took on C
Python 2.7 so if something is 1.0 it
means it took exactly the same amount of
time as it took C Python 2.7 to run if
it's 2 it means it took twice as long as
C Python 2.7 to run and if it's 0.5 it
took half as much so smaller is better
is the key thing and 1.0 means it's a
tie
Claire okay cool so these are all the
benchmarks I'm just going to scroll
through them I don't really expect you
to read them it's mainly just to point
out that there are things here such as
running 2 to 3 over itself
there's checking how fast it takes to do
a call chameleon is templating chaos as
numbers and goes templating you'll
quickly learn that the lemon tree
benchmarks are evil and horrible for
everyone except for C Python 2.7 it's
really shocking I actually have a to do
now to actually verify that something's
not funky going on
there's pickling there's float work
there's some logging which is mostly
string there's JSON loading and dumping
which is more strings in Queens path Lib
pickling basically there's a mix there's
a mismatch of stuff here so let's look
at all this in one unreadable plot
because there's no way in hell you can
make out what the hell this says but
it's pretty the key thing is to point
out that a lot of people up most of this
stuff is really really low and not
completely crazy and there's about three
or four benchmarks that are just insane
so if you can't read that that's 60 so
that's about 60 times slower than C
Python 2.7 and as you'll find out
basically that is III parse III parse as
I said III is elementary is just
horrible it is a nasty nasty benchmark
but basically Matt Paul it made that
cheap to do when I thought it was pretty
so I did it but I'm going to talk about
all the interpreters individually so you
actually had a much better breakdown so
dry thon had some compatibility problems
so this is running without chameleon v2
path Lib tornado and I'm Peck sequence
basically path Lib was a lacking of when
version all the cysts module for
instance unpack sequence basically had
too many method calls that I remember
correctly
these are little compatibility problems
that I'm sure if a bug was filed
Jonathan would fix I should mention I
did not run the startup marks against
anyone could basically if your name is
not see Python it's slow as hell which
is I mean which is fair it's hard to get
that fast
I should mention though pi PI 4
explicitly worked on speeding up startup
for pi PI so things have improved for
them
I just purposely didn't benchmark it
because without that flag things take
one to two hours longer to benchmark and
I only have so much time so as I pointed
out earlier Jonathan had two really bad
benchmarks so the really really tall one
is III parse and the what looks small
but is actually still large because it's
more than 15 times slower is each
retarted parse I as I said I have a to
do on my list now to find out what
Tech's want with that benchmark because
I'm shocked that they're that horrible
and they're not [ __ ] about the other
III III benchmarks but because that
skews the data so high that you can't
really read the charts I chopped it off
at two times so that's two times slower
than C Python and that's what that black
line is that's exactly marginal or
meeting the speed of C Python 2.7 terms
of time so as you can see it's a mix I
mean some things do go past too
obviously but some things are actually
faster
anything missing is basically not run
because of compatibility issues but I
mean it's not a complete blowout which i
think is basically impressive when you
consider you're implementing a highly
highly dynamic programming language and
a not highly highly tuned have a claim
of it at all that being Java so I still
I think it's fairly impressive that they
get these numbers as is so another way
to look at this is to do a box plot with
a scatter plot on top so BOSU does it
does anyone here not know how to read a
balk plot okay that's fine
so basically the way a blocks plot works
is it splits everything up into
quartiles to 25% so that line is the
median so that's exactly half way if you
sorted the performance of all the
benchmarks
that's benchmarks that are the 25% that
are slower 25% that are faster that's
the 25 fastest percent faster and and
then you know 40 can't see it because
the last quartile of the 25 25% most
slowest benchmarks goes off the 2.0
cutoff I have as you can see it's it's
just more or less clustered around 1.0
it's a little top-heavy but it's not
crazy and the 50% right around the
median is all at least on the screen so
once again I think that's still fairly
impressive for implementing a Python in
Java now ironpython you'll notice has a
little bit more compatibility problem in
different ways like django can't run
here versus chameleon which couldn't run
on try thon I should mention tornado is
apparently a really nasty program in
terms of the way it really futz is with
sockets so don't be shocked that it's
not compatible because apparently if you
don't use POSIX sockets directly there's
like no chance you can run it and then
each we at first in run just because
they literally don't implement a lemon
tree to utter parse but overall is
mainly compatible now there is III parse
again it's just evil
I don't know what it is about that
benchmark but that's only real as you
can see the really really nasty outlier
and all this and if you shrunk truncate
down to two there's some that go past I
think it's less than Jai Jai thon in
terms of overall worse than to the
benchmarks once again some are better
some are roughly about the same the ones
they're missing once again we're drop
for compatibility but still I just like
diet then I still think it's fairly
impressive that the benchmarks are both
top and bottom compared to see Python
2.7 if you look at the bar chart as you
can see the whole benchmark suite does
my sans outliers does fit on the screen
so you the top 25 percent card title
does not go past 2.2 times the fastest
doesn't seem to go quite as low as
writhe on but the median is a bit closer
to 1.0 and the spreads like to my mind a
little bit looser and spread out a
little bit more credit Ethel but it does
seem to have a little bit more below 1.0
then dry funded now a pie pie for which
is brand new no compatibility problems
because the pie pie team works very hard
on that fairly recent and you would
expect it to be the fastest and it
basically is you'll notice there is one
really bad performer and that's for some
reason pickle dick I don't know why
and then what the one next to is pick a
list and then PI digits of whole things
but it's 5 versus 40 and 60 so nowhere
near as high up as strength on
ironpython
and as you can see there I've seen ones
that you can barely measure I mean
there's a obviously if there's a handful
that are definitely above two two times
but the vast majority are way below 50%
faster than C Python 2.7 so pi PI
definitely has earned its reputation as
the fastest implementation of Python and
then the really obvious thing is when
you look at the box plot I mean the
whole 50% 25% faster or slower than the
median is completely
below the 1.0 level for matching see
Python 2.7 performance I mean you could
just look at that just obviously know
that pi PI is just faster period now out
of interest because I gave a talk at
PyCon 2013 comparing Python 2 to Python
3 and why you should switch and I
include benchmark numbers I've said
Martin it again and see what does Python
3.5 do you compared to 2.7 because I
still have people telling me 2.7 is
slower than 3.5 sorry I should reverse
that people tell me 3.5 is lower than
2.7 and at that time I did the talk and
I said look it basically works out to be
the same and it still does some things
are faster some things are slower one
thing I'll point out is that is not an
error telco it really is that much
faster that is thanks to the decimal
module being reimplemented in c you can
get that on pi p re though obviously i'd
ran this off stock installs so Teleco
completely trounces C Python 2.7 but as
you can see it's more or less equivalent
there's as I said III either person this
one's slower by over 2 but it's pretty
consistent either a little above or
actually decently below if you aren't
crazy to get it zoom in it's not that
much different obviously but there's no
real like consistently faster or slower
honestly so I think it's pretty
consistent
and if you look at the box plot it's
extremely tight around 1.0 I mean you
can barely make out the median line
above one and it clusters really tightly
and the whole box plot it fits between
0.5 and 1 point 5 Sansa outliers
obviously now as an experiment I decided
to try compiling C Python 3.5 with poor
file gotta optimizations or you might
know it as Pogo using the test Suites
you try to optimize the binary to run as
fast as possible and basically it looks
exactly like the previous chart for
normal C Python 3.5 but all the bars
pushed down slightly
so if you notice all the benchmarks are
no worse than two times slower than 2.7
unlike the previous set of slides and
the box plot is even tighter except this
time the meeting is actually completely
below 1.0 so puzzle Pogo actually
obviously helps actually make Python
faster and then based on time I've got
not much so I'm going to skip the aside
but basically there is only six
benchmarks where it is actually a
hindrance for Pogo versus not and the
overall differences are fairly miniscule
for most of them so I'm going to try to
convince Steve dower to compile Python
release on Windows with Pogo turned on
wish me luck
and then I'm going to quickly talk about
pigeon this is the project that I work
on part-time that adds a JIT interpreter
to see Python unfortunately there was a
bug just before I started to do these
benchmarks so that's why two to three
and chameleons don't run I don't know
why tornado hangs but it does that's a
reason for the incompatibility otherwise
is completely compatible because if it
can't get something it bails out and it
continues to run under the eval loop for
C Python so there's zero compatibility
problems if we didn't have bugs
what can you do
so if you notice if you look at this
it's actually fairly similar to C Python
3.5 which do you know I are actually
fairly happy with because it shows that
at least blindly adding a JIT with like
no optimizations it's almost a
one-to-one translation of take this
Python bytecode and somehow make it have
an equivalent net by code and it isn't
worse right so that's not doing anything
fancy we're like oh no net we have
integer byte codes we can actually start
doing like integer and float and all
this stuff real low-level calculations
and get the performance out of that so
I'm actually happy with this chart if
you zoom in as I said it more or less is
pretty consistent some things are a
little faster some things are somewhat
slower but it's a mixed bag but nothing
completely like oh my god it's so slow
what
hello a wasting our time with and the
boxplot looks somewhat similar to see
python itself the top is a little worse
but everything's shifted a little higher
but it's not complete blowout now to
give a quick overview here all the box
plots side-by-side so it goes cpython
C Python with Pogo ironpython choice on
pi pi and then pigeon so nothing
completely crazy everyone does I think
of fairly admirable job Python 3 no
faster no slower Pogo obviously makes
everything faster
ironpython try thon do an admirable job
considering pi pi is the fastest by far
and pigeon does not make me want to stop
working on it now to give it more
concrete view if you take the geometric
mean overall the benchmarks this is the
chart you get so once again see python
python with c python 3 with pogo rock
python Jai thon pi PI and pigeon which
also made me very happy because pigeon
is still as a geometric mean average
faster than C breath on 2.7 so continues
to make me not want to stop working on
it C Python 3.5 though I found fairly
interesting is actually below 1.0 so for
those of you who say 2.7 is faster
overall I don't believe you anymore Oh
actually depends on your workload but
I'm no longer taking it too seriously
when people say slower slower I'm
obviously biased though so what can you
do so just wrap up we got a lot of
options which is fantastic this
community is fantastic and seems to love
the language enough that they actually
like to re-implement the whole bloody
thing which is great because it gives us
lots of options for your needs and
considering how demmick dynamic the
language is I'm really impressed that
the performance is as close it is for
all the interpreters and if any of this
is interested you all you want to help
some of these people do better they're
all open source
the altai contributions and that's it
any questions and thank you saying for
saying to the very end it's very
consistent it can shift maybe a couple
percent like one or I think I've never
seen more than a three percent shift
between runs but it's not like suddenly
you're really fast and really slow it's
it the consistency is really good this
is why all the benchmarks are relative
to another interpreter and why we use it
because the lien SWA was doing tissues
sake are we doing better than we were
previously that reliability of the
comparison makes sure that if for some
reason my the benchmark machine was
actually slower that day for who knows
what was running in the background
both interpreters get screwed over so no
one's looses up and that's why I didn't
show up absolute performance numbers
because it just doesn't really ten out
yeah it's more about who's faster
overall okay it's um yeah they're not
compatible enough yet so the have gotten
far enough to run their benchmarks but
for instance they haven't implemented
the format built-in like they have
they're still flying short enough that
like just earlier this like yeah I think
in April or May they announced that they
were compatible enough to run their own
their own little scripts in their in
their check out so they're getting there
and they can obviously run some things
but they if you look at their like
issues is like implement this implement
that so it's just they're not quite
there yet
give them the ear and they'll probably
be there this is my suspicion because
they're also pulling a lot of code
directly out of cpython
because they've decided to somewhat take
the approach the pigeon is in a way of
let's adage it on top of cpython almost
so it's allowing them to really
accelerate their development
well yeah well so that so the deal with
pipe eyes it kind of depends on the
project look at so pipe I has the numpy
PI project where they're more or less
for my understanding implementing numpy
in our Python but for instance I think
part of the reason that project fix so
long and it led to the CFO Phi project
so for instance if any of these
libraries decided to use scythe on I
believe sights on supports pi PI
so scikit-learn I believe is fine but if
you use something like type I itself or
whatever if they use CF fi the instantly
get possi Python and pipe rights work
but once again that requires the project
to actually do that kind of switch which
obviously can take a bit of effort yeah
but I mean the other hope is I think if
Jonathan and I write Python pickups EFI
which they have mentioned they're
seriously thinking about you would
suddenly get all the interpreters to
work with the C extension which would be
fantastic but that's a material issue
that I don't know as possible someone's
done it anyone else
Oh trans projects yeah just what do I
know about it so so Trent Nelson for
those who don't know developed a project
called PI parallel which basically is a
fork of C Python where he trying to
introduce parallelism by kind of
ignoring the guilt more or less it runs
only on Windows and he gets really good
performance numbers but like you it's
it's kind of like freezes rough counts
the deal is much like stackless it kind
of requires you to use certain built-ins
in order to get the parallelism because
you kind of have to say this is parallel
and okay go run it this way and none of
the benchmarks are structured that way
so there's no like inherent it'll
automatically run faster you have to
actually decide to use the performance
of it to get it so it's not implicit
like a jet it's more explicit like this
or the soft regions actual memory stuff
that the pi pi team is doing that kind
of thing but I haven't heard anything
since language summit but Trent seems to
like to muck with it so I think it's
always under development somehow any
other questions to language about Python
2 and python 3 I mean that's completely
up to you guys I would be totally happy
the world just ran in Python but you
guys have to be willing to give up the C
code first because I don't think you're
suggesting you give up Python for C cuz
you gotta pry that up my dead bed hands
so I mean we're always obviously working
to make Python faster it really depends
it's it's hard to do right everyone's
workloads different and what seems fast
and everyone's needs are different like
what's fast to me is dead slow to like
Google or someone who's like get
hardcore I gotta shave a millisecond off
of every request that hits my web server
because god forbid it take a more
millisecond which makes sense for some
people went off brother so
no there's no way in hell you're ever
gonna do that just because there's
always gonna be that speed nut you just
can't give up that little bit yeah
that's fine that's their decision if
they want to put the time in but it if
they don't use for instance if they
don't you see if if I it's really
unfortunate because it really locks them
to cpython in securing the the healthy
ecosystem of interpreters we have to
actually use it so I would suggest
anyone who's about to write new rappers
do concer CFO five for that yep well
okay so PO go there so there's Sebago is
available on windows through visual
studio and then it's also available
through clang and LLVM and also on GCC
intel actually to view the patches for
our make file so I should say this any
of you who compile Python yourself use
the poco build okay it was added in
three five and into seven make sure you
build with it
intel's benchmarked it and as you saw
here there's basically no reason not to
except for very explicit situations
now you can obviously also use this to
do your own benchmarking with your own
workloads to make sure that your pogo
build is actually optimized specifically
for your workload but if you don't put
that much effort in i would still do
that now if you're on a boom - boom
she's been doing this for years so
you're already getting it for free but
if you do hand builds you should
definitely do this um why for instance
steve hasn't turned on by default I last
time I brought this off which I think
was last week well I mean I was working
on this literally until Thursday so we
haven't sat down and talked about me
I'll talk about with him tonight there
are still a couple cases where it
doesn't perform better as you as I
quickly breeze through because the time
there's like six benchmarks it's a
little slower but I mean some of them
are like 2% like or 7% slower nothing
like there's only like two or three
they're double digit and Steve's not
convinced that the test suite is the
best workload to do for the measurement
build to measure before it does the poco
bell to do the optimizations
I want to challenge him to say well okay
what would you use instead and I suspect
he's gonna say I don't know in which
case I'm gonna press on and say well
then I say choose my option because I
have one and you don't I win haha
but I I can't for Steve to choose that
for the windows builds no are there any
continued idolic employees in the room I
would ask their bet I would ask their
desk tomorrow possibly as I said a blue
Tory does it I'd be a little surprised
if they don't already but yeah it's a
good question I don't know I think they
should do if they don't I don't know yet
pigeon is obviously still in heavy
development I would even call it an
Elfie yet I'm so I don't know about that
number obviously is being written by
continuum the larva seer numpy experts
and it's designed to actually JIT numpy
stuff so it'll actually JIT numpy
operations pi pi obviously is still
working on theirs I know they'd shown
benchmarks where it's fast but it's one
of those they're not finished with their
compatible huh yeah so it's one of those
I don't know yet obviously we hope with
pigeon much like I'm sure with number
that if you're doing like straight
integer or float work and we can detect
it just isn't it you need to box those
numbers you can just do it straight in
the dotnet bytecode and just do native
floating in pork so we're we're those
are like the first lowing in first we're
gonna hit anyway so we're hoping to get
some decent numbers out of that yep
so I thought you mean pipe ice I found
support pipe i I believe it does
I believe the papaya team worked with
scythe on in order to make sure that
they got that supporting because I mean
it's all auto-generated right so they
just have to make sure they ought to
generate in a way that pipe I can read
it so this is one of the reasons why
doing using scythe on our CFO fie and
their whole reason they create CFO I to
make it even easier was because it says
it's auto-generated it's just a flip of
something to make it just I want that
for pipe I want that for cpython versus
when you do it by hand it's like you
have no chance in hell of working with
pipe I or anyone else whoever decides
this for it and where else
oh why I think that parts it may have
started before they got the scythe on
support I don't know that this you'd
have to ask the pipe I people I'm not
really involved with the project I know
the numpy PI project has been around for
a decent amount of time so it's a
question of I don't know the timeline I
don't know when did sorry I don't get
pipe I when did see if I know CF if I
start it after and I and at this point I
don't know where it lies because once
again you have to realize sometimes pipe
are sexy faster than C because that JIT
is that good sometimes it actually beats
out C code so it's also one of those if
you want absolute fastest and they can
pull off numpy pi it's possible we'll
still be faster than scythe on but then
again it could potentially get the
compatibility sooner so I don't know ask
the pipe I people they're fairly
responsive actually if you want to tweet
at them they'll probably give you an
answer anywhere else all right thanks
everybody
you